einen wunderschönen nachmittag meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren ich darf
sie im namen des österreichischen
bundesheeres im speziellen tag garde zur
heutigen angelobung von 167 rekruten des
einberufungstermin es juli 2020 recht
herzlich begrüßen
mein name ist was man isst rainer fragen
ich habe die ehrenvolle aufgabe den nun
folgenden festakt zu moderieren
aufgrund der derzeitigen
gesundheitssituation und der damit
verbundenen einschränkungen für
veranstaltungsbesucher haben wir uns
entschlossen den heutigen angelobung
festakt live im internet zu übertragen
ich darf ihnen vorab die aufstellung der
ausgerückten truppe bekanntgeben
ich beginne dazu von mir aus gesehen
links mit dem fell zeichen
danach steht die militärmusik
niederösterreich unter der leitung von
stabführer obacht meister hannes kompass
und im anschluss der ehrenzug gestellt
von der ersten garde kompanie danach
stehen die rekruten der garde und in
weiterer folge von mir aus gegen rechts
die wachen funktion soldaten des
einberufungstermin es juli 2020 die in
wenigen minuten wird der festakt mit
einem ankündigungs signal für einen
trompeter der militärmusik beginnen
danach meldet der kommandant der
ausgerückten truppe oberreiter und
matthias schmidt dem stellvertretenden
militärkommandanten von wien oberst
gerhard sky wie es folgen die
bundeshymne das abschreiten der front
und die flaggenparade
[Musik]
das ganze hat ihre zog ihren zu pressen
das ganze recht
herr oberst oberleutnant schmidt meldet
ein ehrenzug der gabe der militärmusik
niederösterreich und 167 grundwehrdiener
zur feierlichen angelobung angetreten
mit dem festakt beginnen
[Musik]
ihren sohn ihren zog das ganze parade
das ganze paktieren zog ihre zu pressen
tipp zur flaggenparade das ganze recht
ob
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das taktieren zog ihren zog
das ganze parade
es erfolgt nun die begrüßung durch den
stellvertretenden kommandanten der garde
oberstleutnant thomas franz grüter
berger danach spielt die gardemusik ich
berichte die militärmusik
niederösterreich einen choral und zu
hören die worte der geistlichkeit
der faire handel ist eine geschätzte
kameraden meine damen und herren es
haben sich trotz dieser bedingungen wo
die angelobung jahr ohne weise in der
öffentlichkeit spricht der angehörigen
stattfinden muss ehrengäste eingefunden
die diesen festakt wo die anwesenheit
auszeichnen und ich darf das militär
schützt anwesenden begrüßen den
stellvertretenden militärkommandanten
oberste herz karikaturist als zivilen
höchster wissen die politisch höchst
anwesend da sich begrüßen den
abgeordneten zum wiener landtag herr
magister marcus schober servus gemacht
ich darf wieder begrüßen die
bezirksvorsteherin der s13 china weil
gemeindebezirks unseres heimatbezirks
frau magister silke kowald grüß gott ein
aufrichtiges christ und richtig da weil
die der geistlichkeit allen voran herrn
mit der ärzte kann unsere mit der
pfarrer dr harald priez sehr geschätzte
kameraden die hier angelockt werden
sie sind angerückt bei der garde und die
jahre ist ein einsatzverband was das
bedeutet werden sie in den nächsten
tagen wochen und monaten noch
kennenlernen zumindest sehr viele von
ihnen die gerade ist
unbeschadet der korona situation
grundsätzlich immer im einsatz für
repräsentation aber auch für
assistenzeinsätze jahrelang schon an den
grenzen österreichs tätig dort die
sicherheitsbehörden zu unterstützen
mittlerweile auch noch durch die krone
situation mit hilfe leistungen
eingeteilt das möchte ich nur kurz
erwähnen die post hilfeleistung
enzersdorf wo die jahre soldaten
eingeteilt wurden die calls ein
callcenter betreuung bei der ags beim
außenministerium die auch jetzt wieder
angelaufen ist der minister was sie
sehen
ihnen wird nicht langweilig oder fad
werden
sie werden ihren dienst als garde
soldaten die hier vorne stehen
verrichten die dann eben diese einsätze
hautnah und live durchzuführen haben
werden
und ich erwarte mir als gar die sonate
von ihnen leistungsbereitschaft
das ist das was ich die gerade und die
österreichische bevölkerung von ihnen
erwartet leistungsbereitschaft die
anderen kameraden die ja so genannte
funktion soldaten in diversen funktionen
eben ihre dienste versehen in vach
funktionen mit unterstützen dass das
system teilweise aufrecht erhalten
bleibt bzw auch vielfach vorgesetzen
unterstützen zur hand gehen
von denen wird gewissenhaftigkeit
erwartet sie sollen ihren vorgesetzten
mit gewissenhaftigkeit bei der arbeit
dienlich sein und ganz wesentlich einer
der vornehmsten dienste weg der
wachdienst die wachsoldaten nomen est
omen von ihnen wird wachsamkeit erwartet
lassen sie keine routine einkehren die
sie zu fehlern verleitet bleiben sie
wachsam
gerade in zeiten wie diesen am rand seit
75 jahren hat es österreich geschafft
keinen konkreten militärischen krieg
ausrichten zu müssen
die korona situation kommt dem überhaupt
nicht mehr was vor 75 jahren hier in
mitteleuropa zu ende gegangen ist
das heißt es ist eine absolut
militärisch bewältigbare aufgabe für
jeden und das werden sie auch in kürze
bei ihrer angelobung der
österreichischen bevölkerung versprechen
dass sie für die bevölkerung geben diese
aufträge und diesem einsatz bestehen
ich darf mich im zuge dessen auch haben
einen kader personalräten jahren
komponierte danken für die ausbildung
der rekruten unternehmen nicht einfachen
bedingungen von rahmenbedingungen und
darf den kameraden die in kürze angelobt
werden
vorweg schon einmal alles gute wünschen
für ihre tätigkeiten in den
verschiedensten funktionen bleiben sie
gesund halten sie die einschlägigen
bestimmungen sicherheitsbestimmungen in
sachen corona ein nicht nur im dienst
sondern auch zu hause bleiben sie gesund
und ich wünsche ihnen für den weiteren
verlauf ihres dienstes und die einsätze
alles gute
o
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr oberste vertretung
unseres militärkommandanten von wien
wird der vertreter des öffentlichen
lebens aber insbesondere in dieser
stunde der angelobung werte an zu
geloben die kameraden der garde
sie geloben heute feierlich mit allen
ihren kräften der republik österreich
und dem österreichischen volk zu dienen
dieses gelöbnis zu leben im alltag ihres
soldatischen dienstes können sie
natürlich nicht aus sich selbst
dazu bedarf es eines großen vertrauens
und auch sehr oft der übernatürlichen
kräfte unseres gottes im alten testament
heißt es in einem psalm so schön lehre
mich deinen willen zu tun denn du bist
mein gott wie ein guter geist leite mich
auf einem pfad und deines namens willen
herr erhalt mich am leben führe mich
heraus aus der not in deiner
gerechtigkeit liebe kameraden der wunsch
ist dass schon ab morgen für sie alle
die sie im dienst stehen an der grenze
ebene pfade und wege die meiste zeit des
grundwehrdienstes darstellen mögen aber
was will dieser psalm und sagen es meint
der geist gottes muss sie führen und
muss sie leiten
gott allein kann ihren dienst um soll
ihren dienst auch beleben wir kameraden
wer sich im glauben und im gehorsam
durch den geist gottes belehren und
führen lässt und auch manchmal mit und
untereinander im alltäglichen dienst in
der compagnie de erfährt dann auch eine
wunderbare belebung dieses soldatischen
alltags in dienst erfüllung und
kameradschaft aber natürlich auch und
das möglichst auch geben in den privaten
mußestunden abseits des dienstes diese
belebung wünsche ich wünschen wir ihnen
heute wo sie geloben allen ihre kräfte
und damit all ihr seien für ihren dienst
als soldat unserer heimat österreich
einzusetzen
gott schenke ihnen reichen segen dazu
und bewahre sie vor allem unheil und
schaden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie hören jetzt die ansprache des
stellvertreter die militärkommandanten
von wien oberst gerd sky will und danach
spricht in vertretung des bürgermeisters
und landeshauptmann es von wien
der abgeordnete zum wiener landtag und
gemeinderat magister marcus schober
sehr geehrter abgeordneter frau
bezirksvorsteherin hohe geistlichkeit
insbesondere aber sie an zu gelogen der
rekruten der garde
ich darf es ja stimmen der konserve
willkommen heißen sich anfang juli war
gerade ein gericht um ihre wehrpflicht
zu erfüllen und unmittelbar nach dem
ende hatten verlegten sie für die
basisausbildung zu unserem schon
traditionellen stützpunkt nach vorn und
zwei viertel
dort lernten sie einerseits das
mythische handwerk andererseits gilt es
aber auch sich in ihrer neuen
lebenssituation einzufinden
gemeinsam mit ihren kameraden in einer
aufforderung zu bestehen
sie tun dies in besonderen zeiten seien
früher prägten einer pandemie die
gestaltung des dienstes einerseits und
die auftragslage andererseits die guard
ist der bekanntlich der repräsentations
verband des österreichischen bundesheers
neben der repräsentation gibt es
allerdings einsatzaufkommen und diese
prägende zeit mit diesen den dienst ganz
besonders beispielhaft rückblickend und
ausblick erwähnte assistenzeinsatz für
polizei und gesundheitsbehörden selbst
bewachung von botschaften kritische
infrastruktur wir warten der
staatsgrenze im burgenland
gesundheitskontrollen zum beispiel auch
am flughafen schwechat unterstützung von
callcenter verschiedener behörden und
institutionen wie außenministerium
agentur für gesundheit
verteilungszentren brust aufbietung von
zwei blitz kompanien auch eine besondere
leistung und eine herausforderung und
letztendlich der einsatz der fünften
kompanie in bosnien die vorige woche
verabschiedet wurde
und wie rasch sich die zeiten ändern und
die lage sich ändert zeigt der wunderbar
vorstellt der assistenzeinsatz dritten
garde kompanie in die steiermark wo es
dabei weder von tagen eigentlich regiert
werden musste für diese arbeit und die
flexible kreative auftragserfüllung
möchten den kommandanten der gerade und
dem gesamten kader besser ankommen
anerkennung aussprechen und ich kann das
schon beurteilen ich glaube und ich
beurteile so dass die garde sicherte am
ehesten ausgelastete verband des
österreichischen bundesheer ist sehr gut
nicht dagegen dass sie sich vor dem dies
im bus entschlossen haben in kürze
versprechen sie im treuegelöbnis dass
sie persönlich zur auftragserfüllung des
bundesrats beitragen und der
österreichischen bevölkerung schutz und
hilfe leisten werden
ihr beitrag das sehen wir jetzt bei den
offenen einsatz ist eine entscheidung da
nur gemeinsam mit den berufssoldaten und
milizsoldaten und ihnen als kunde innern
ist der erfüllung der vielfältigen
aufgaben des bundes als möglich und wie
man sich aus tätig werden und ihren
beitrag sicher leisten sei es bei der
garde oder auch im rahmen des dings
betriebes in der therapie unterstützung
bei der wache ich wünsche ihnen als
schlittert mit der konsulin für die vor
ihnen liegende zeit und ihre tätigkeiten
und herausfahren alles erdenklich gute
und viel erfolg und vor allem zeit mit
diesen bleiben sie gesund danken
sehr geehrter kommandant sehr geehrte
frau bezirksvorsteherin wert der
soldaten und soldatinnen der garde aber
vor allem sie werte rekruten die eigene
angelobung das etwas ganz besonderes und
es ist natürlich unser kalender zeiten
eine andere voraussetzung dass heute
nicht ihre familie ihre liebsten auch
hier anwesend sein können und ich hoffe
dass einige doch heute zuschauen können
und dass sie das auch noch mit ihrer
familie nachträglich feiern können das
heute diese angelobung stattgefunden hat
ich kann mich sehr gut in sie
hineinversetzen ich war selbst hier bei
der gerade und bin hier gestanden und
natürlich stellt man sich gerade bei der
angelobung bei der eigenen an gelungen
die angelobung die frage warum stehe ich
hier und was mache ich hier und ich kann
ihnen garantieren seit 1955 an dass sehr
viele kameraden kann man ihn angemacht
und der großteil von ihnen hat diese
frage beantwortet nämlich diese frage in
die tat umgesetzt und für die republik
österreich in den unterschiedlichsten
ebenen im einsatz und in vielen anderen
bereichen leistung gezeigt die bis heute
von vielen anerkannt wird
ich glaube es war 1960 die richtige
entscheidung dass österreich sich für
internationale einsätze entschieden hat
das war der erste einsatz im kongo und
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass
dieser einsatz dazu zählt dazu geführt
hat dass wien heute der einzige uno sitz
in europa ist und dass unser einsatz
auch noch heute dazu beitrag beiträgt
dass österreich eine hohe reputation im
ausland hat egal mit welchem soldaten
und soldatinnen aus dem ausland spricht
das österreichische bundesheer hat eine
hohe anerkennung und das glaube ich ist
auch der grund dass berufssoldaten und
milizsoldaten im ausland und im inland
ganz eng zusammenarbeiten
der kommandant habe schon gesagt seit
1955 in den friedenseinsatz und das ist
ein sehr wichtiger einsatz in europa sie
haben jetzt ihre grundausbildung hinter
sich und es wurde auch schon gesagt dass
sie mit morgen auch in den einsatz gehen
der kommandant hat auch schon gesagt was
da auf sie zukommt und ich möchte ihnen
da alles gute wünschen und mich auch bei
ihnen bedanken
ich glaube es ganz wichtig dass über
alle parteigrenzen hinweg auf geschaut
wird dass das österreichische bundesheer
bestmöglich finanziert wird
es ist nicht leicht in zeiten von caron
aber ich merke schon dass da ein großes
interesse ist dass das österreichische
bundesheer über finanzierung und nötige
finanzierung verfügt was mir beim
bundesheer auffällt ist dass unsere
einsätze relativ rasch in vergessenheit
geraten
ich möchte auch nur hier erinnern 2015
in der flüchtlingskrise hat allein das
militärkommando wien über eine million
mahlzeiten zur verfügung gestellt ich
möchte in einen einsatz 2009 10 in
österreich im schnee untergegangen ist
und jetzt in der aktuellen krise
meisters österreichische bundesheer was
von anfang an den einsatz war und sie
werden jetzt diesen einsatz erweitert ja
natürlich auch durch eine
teilmobilmachung der miliz gestartet
wurde und jetzt fortgeführt wird
ich darf vielleicht noch kurz auf das
internationale ansprechen weil ich kann
mich erinnern wie ich eingerückt bin war
keine frage davon dass wir probleme in
weißrussland haben das in der ukraine
eine krise ist dass die türkei instabile
verhältnisse hat das ein großer krieg im
nahen osten herrscht dass der libanon
jetzt durch diese katastrophe
erschütterung ist und ich könnte das bis
ägypten und libyen weiter ziehen
man sieht einfach dass international
rund um europa sehr viel passiert und
dass sicherheit nicht selbstverständlich
ist deswegen noch mal der appell dass
wir auch da schauen dass die
rahmenbedingungen schaffen
ich habe anfangs gesagt die frage die
man sich stellt warum steht man hier
vielleicht darf ich aus meiner sicht
beantworten für mich war das immer eine
klare entscheidung zum österreichischen
bundesheer zu gehen weil ich es wichtig
finde dass wenn einer liberalen
demokratie leben das wir freie menschen
sind dass wir unsere meinung frei äußern
können und dafür stehen sie auch und das
werden sie jetzt auch geloben
vielleicht bleibt einer von ihnen auch
als berufssoldat beim bundesheer
vielleicht als milizsoldaten ich würde
mich sehr freuen wenn sie sich das
anschauen und wenn sie sehen welche
möglichkeiten sie beim österreichischen
bundesheer hätten
wien ist stolz auf sie weil sie sind der
garant dafür dass sie helfen können wenn
andere nicht mehr helfen können
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
es lebe die republik österreich
[Applaus]
nach einer fanfare kommen wir nun zum
höhepunkt dieses festaktes dem
treuegelöbnis es wird heute von rekrut
bernhard händel vorgesprochen
[Musik]
das ganze in sentrup der garde vertreten
eingeteilte rekruten vortreten
denn so
rekruten spricht mir nach ich glaube
mein vaterland die republik österreich
und sein volk zu schützen und mit der
waffe zu verteidigen
ich gelobe den gesetzen und den
gesetzmäßigen behörden
[Applaus]
treue und gehorsam zu leisten
alle befehle meiner vorgesetzten
pünktlich und genau zu befolgen und mit
all meinen kräften
der republik österreich und dem
österreichischen volker eingeteilt der
rekruten eintreten
in singen drucker gerade eintreten
das ganze parade
[Musik]
der kombi nannte aufrückten truppe
oberleitung und matthias schmidt bietet
nun um weitere befehle und mit dem
ausmaß stellen siegen und dem abrücken
der information ist dieser festakt
beendet ich darf mich an dieser stelle
namens des hessischen bundesheeres unter
garde einzusehen verabschieden und ihnen
einen schönen tag wünscht ihren zu
pressen
das ganze recht
herr oberst oberleutnant schmidt meldet
die beendigung des feierlichen festaktes
und der bitte um weitere befehle
abrücken das ganze hab taktieren zog sie
ihren job muss das ganze parat
das ganze hat ihren sohn ihren pässen
tipp zum ausmaß des single obst das
ganze recht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ihre zog ihren zog kommandant zog
kommando übernehmen abrücken
[Musik]